so upon her return from her 12-hour
twitter ban
radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green announced she's
holding a press
conference in her office the press
conference was
primarily um highlighted by terrible
audio where you can barely hear the
people asking the questions
and you can barely hear marjorie taylor
green we've
uh amped up the audio level so that you
hopefully will be able to hear it
and this first question goes right to
i don't know how these right wingers get
fixated on bogus talking points
that make no sense but they do and
marjorie taylor green is a big proponent
of the
hippa bogus vaccine talking
point all right so let's listen to this
one first aaron navarro cbs news
uh whip scalia said today he got
vaccinated siding this delta variant
that's going around and said he's
confident that it's safe and effective
two questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
you see with hipaa rights we don't have
to reveal our medical records and that
also involves our vaccine records
so that is a complete and total lie this
has been repeated
sean hannity has said it marjorie taylor
green has said it a bunch of times
a journalist asking a public figure who
is talking about the merits of
vaccination
is not a violation of hipaa rights hippa
stipulates how information that is
held by health care and healthcare
insurance companies
has to be protected from fraud and theft
it relates to the digital transmission
of such
information and uh it relates to
those entities exclusively it has
nothing to do with
media questions it just has nothing to
do with it
when you go into a doctor's office and
you're given something that's their
privacy policy and how they protect your
data
and who they will share data that's
governed by hipaa
when you are a congresswoman who lies
about vaccines
and a journalist says are you vaccinated
the question doesn't violate anything
related to hipaa
she's not forced to answer she didn't by
the way
and it's genuinely stunning that i mean
i know stupid talking points catch on
this is a really really stupid talking
point and i tweeted about this last
night
saying could anybody tell her that hipaa
relates to medical providers and privacy
not journalists
asking public figures questions one
common reaction was basically
david she's been vaccinated but she
wants
to give certain people who follow her
the idea that she hasn't
because that's what a lot of her whole
indignant
perspective and approach is predicated
on the idea that she's opposing the
vaccine and putting her money where her
mouth is or putting
her health where her mouth is when in
reality she's been vaccinated
maybe that's the case i don't know maybe
she has been vaccinated
but if you're telling everyone to be
skeptical of the vaccine
it's relevant and completely appropriate
for journalists to say have you been
vaccinated
now let's continue just a couple other
disgusting moments from this thing
she was uh she as in her statement
she said something about if you're not
obese
and you're not over 65 you're not gonna
die
so therefore you don't need to be
vaccinated and someone points out to her
skinny people and kids have also died
and she just laughs
dangerous do you feel any responsibility
for keeping
people in georgia safe you know there
are children
skinny people who have died of the
coronavirus do you feel
any responsibility to
um you know what i think people's
responsibility is their own
so this is just continued disgusting
stuff
um i mentioned this when we talked about
when joe rogan
said a couple months ago young people
don't need to get vaccinated there's no
reason for young people to get
vaccinated i'm paraphrasing
uh and he said you know if you eat a
good diet and you exercise
i have looked and have still found no
study that suggests diet and exercise
makes you less susceptible
to the virus in terms of an infection
which you may then
spread certainly underlying health
makes you less likely to have a serious
case that's true but we live in a
society folks
and this stuff from marjory taylor green
is just disgusting
one last moment a marjorie taylor green
lashed out at marie newman in a
transphobic rant marie newman is a
congressional
candidate newman's daughter is
transgender newman has talked about how
the lack of support for trans people and
trans youth
influenced her running for office and
here's marjorie taylor green
in a transphobic rant congresswoman
marie newman just called you a deeply
broken person and hoped that
you would get some help do you have any
response to this
i think um my colleague democrat marie
newman that is across the hall from me
uh should probably get some help herself
because she's the one
that attacked me on a on a video
by planning a flag out there in the
hallway but starting on my name plate
you see she started that you do
understand that right
she started it guys she started by a
video on my name plate
and then it pans to her where in a
militant fashion she plants a flag
but you know and then she talks about
her um biological son
who she calls her daughter and she talks
about one
she and of course i hope you guys know
when using this phraseology of
her son who she calls her daughter
which completely delegitimizes every
aspect
of of transgender individuals it's just
maureen newman is just calling something
a different name than it actually should
be called right
it's completely dehumanizing she wants
her son to be able to go
in women's bathrooms and have all the
same rights as women
but you know what i have daughters too
and i don't want men
in my daughter's bathroom so just a
completely disgusting bathroom
a transphobic bathroom rant from marjory
taylor green
really truly genuinely a despicable
person
if she gets reelected and she's she's
presumably going to run we are
really going to have to concede that
this virus of trumpism
is probably going to be here to stay for
some significant period of time
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
14th anniversary sale offering everybody
in my audience a subscription for under
three
bucks a month purevpn is a
service i trust because it has more
servers than any other vpn on the market
and it's the only vpn with an always-on
third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged
purevpn keeps me anonymous online
keeps me safe from hackers government
surveillance any websites trying to
track me
and it lets me also access awesome
streaming content
which wouldn't otherwise be available in
my country on platforms like netflix and
a whole bunch of others
i can stay logged into purevpn on up to
10 of my devices at the same time
and it's so easy to use you click two
buttons to set it up
you need no computer expertise at all
you can get pure vpn at a huge discount
just 288 a month
when you go to davidpakman.com vpn the
link is right under this video
and you'll get an additional 14 off
when you use the coupon code hbd
14.